hmm
how's it going everybody it's warren and
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe and today we have
an interesting loki teaser trailer this
was from
boss logic now here's the kicker it's
hard to know
what exactly this means because boss
logic does actually work for marvel
studios he also works for dc as well
boss logic does a lot for marvel studios
he does a lot of designs in fact he did
a lot for spider-man far from home and
the recent black adam teaser trailer
that was shown at dc's fandom was
done completely by bosslogic and his
team and the trailer that he did
was the official teaser trailer and the
rock even posted it on all of his social
medias talking about the black adam film
and this is the trailer that they showed
for black adam during the panel at dc
fandom so the question
is is this something that's somewhat
official from
marvel studios that bosslogic has been
working on and even if it's not
doesn't mean anything because we know
that supposedly next week
is when production is supposed to resume
for the falcon and the winter soldier we
also know that other films and projects
are supposed
to resume filming again this month as
well and loki is supposed to be one of
those shows that's supposed to kick back
up again soon so does this mean that we
can expect something from the loki
series relatively soon we've all been
waiting for
several teaser trailers for a very long
time the falcon and the winter soldier
series
the one division series and the loki
series we got one teaser during the
super bowl that showed us a little bit
of
each of these series and ever since then
months and months ago we've been waiting
for
official teasers and now that production
is resuming again on a lot of projects
maybe we can get them soon and perhaps
this
is teasing that something related to
loki is coming soon as well
but regardless i thought it was a little
cool teaser let me know what you think
about this in the comments down below
also don't forget to subscribe so you
can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a hawkeye funko pop i'm
picking a winner on monday and i'm also
giving away five funko pops on instagram
and five on twitter so be sure to follow
me on there
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof